para unos días es un verdadero placer un
saludo para su audiencia buenos
principios que decir que el proceso
electoral seguido los eeuu se ha
realizado conforme a los parámetros de
ilegalidad hemisférico
es una digamos un proceso electoral que
digamos muestra una clara victoria del
candidato demócrata
y me parece que no hay ningún argumento
para cuestionar la validez o pedir
recuentos bueno en principio en eeuu
existe una comisión federal electoral y
luego de comisiones estatales estas son
las autoridades electorales las campañas
o los las candidaturas pueden pedir a
las autoridades electorales locales no
un recuento de votos siempre y cuando
haya un argumento coherente no acá
verdaderamente no se encuentra un
argumento coherente parece más bien un
mecanismo de dilación y absolutamente
digamos injustificado no de ir el
proceso de procesamiento de resultados
electorales ahora depende de jueces
locales estatales no admitir estas estos
pedidos para recuentos y ciertamente
contra lo resuelto por un juez estatal
se puede acudir a la suprema corte
federal para pedir que revoque en todo
caso una orden no modifique la decisión
de un juez estatal
ciertamente hay en un circuito que
implicaría un mediano placer o no
pero repito no hay argumento para poder
sostener que hay irregularidades en el
proceso electoral le quiero preguntar si
puede llegar a alguno de estos reclamos
de donaldson a la corte suprema del país
y qué escenarios podemos esperar
entonces
yo creo que en principio para ir a la
corte suprema requeriría pues que haya
una denegatoria o pronunciamiento previo
a nivel de jueces digamos estatales y en
la corte suprema de los estados unidos
tradicionalmente ha sido un mecanismo de
muchas garantías no es respeto a la
institucionalidad y yo creo que es muy
difícil por no decir imposible que haya
a nivel de la corte suprema o incluso a
nivel de los jueces de primer instancia
de jueces estatales que haya la
posibilidad de una modificación de cómo
se ha producido el conteo hasta ahora
las autoridades electorales han sido
bastante prolijas para procesar los
resultados y los resultados que se han
emitido al parecer se ajustan plenamente
a la voluntad de los electores ahora sí
es cierto de que preocupa la actitud del
presidente tras lo que está usando la
condición de presidente permitir
pronunciamientos que pueden generar
inestabilidad en la ciudadanía en
américa latina por ejemplo está
prohibido que las autoridades que
postulan al cargo de reelección
utilicen la condición del cargo o sea la
infraestructura para poder pronunciarse
porque eso implica lo que en américa
latina llamamos dirección americana
inflación es el principio de oralidad
eso haré preocupante el presidente tram
está incurriendo en infracción hacia la
neutralidad está usando la condición de
presidente para cuestionarse nole en el
funcionamiento de los organismos
electorales